now we are coming across more and more
unemployment claimants
who say they are having money taken from
their accounts it's been an issue of
recent
many say once the money is gone it's
really hard to get it back very complex
process
joe mohler is going to break it down for
you he spoke to a handful of people
having this issue he now joins us live
from my home to your home joe
yeah claimants tell me that when they go
to report these missing funds they
simply don't know what to do next they
say it's
sort of a back and forth game between
dieter and bank of america
and i looked at the account and 643 have
been removed
more unemployment claimants say they are
missing money from their deter issued
bank of america debit cards
i have been told several things by
multiple agents
when i've called after reporting the
missing funds several people told me
they were told by the bank that dieter
closed the claim but when they checked
with theater nothing changed
i called again today and she said this
closed and that i would need to reach
out
that unemployment closed the account
which i checked online and my claim is
still open
some say their entire accounts are
frozen while deter is still allegedly
depositing money
i can't even go on the website and check
my account others say after getting a
new car they can't get the missing money
claims resolved and they don't know
where to turn
one nice lady i spoke to said what
happens is bank of america is so
flooded with claims that they cannot
keep up with it
so after a certain amount of time when
they can't
investigate your claim they just close
it this issue has been happening in
california too
according to cal matters california and
nevada and maryland are the only states
where departments don't do personal
direct
deposits claimants get debit cards a
lawmaker in california introduced a bill
to try and change that there
to curb this problem they're blaming bfa
saying that they did it that they don't
freeze cards
so i call back bank of america i'm going
back and forth since the 9th
a bank of america told me if a card is
frozen the state has to direct them to
unfreeze it
even today i'm like at this point i was
like fed up because i'm like i'm never
going to get this money
whatever the case is no matter what i
try
i did speak to a person from bank of
america today they are looking into
those claims that we just had in that
story they they tell me if somebody is
issued they're
worried about this issue with their
account there is an option under the
bank of america
portal online to set up a transfer an
automatic transfer to yet another
account
uh we also did reach out to data
regarding this uh they said they'll be
getting back to us
they were meeting about it today and as
far as lost wages assistance i've been
getting a lot of messages about that
people still missing payments we have
yet to get an update on that
just stay with us for the latest
reporting live joe mohler eight news now